all right my last question um how many
of these folks building
software companies that you see
yourself included are non-technical
that's a great question and if they are
non-technical what do they do
yep
um so i'm a developer or it was i
haven't written code in years but we
actually at so we do a state of
independent sas survey and we put out a
report and it like an industry report
and
we asked the question
do you have
at least one technical founder right or
you know and yes or no right and
the number of
sas companies kind of bootstrap dish sas
companies with zero with no technical
founders is like 20 i believe it's 20
percent 25 wow it's very possible
it is
and usually what the expertise they have
they're either the subject matter expert
like
we're going to build software for
accountants i was an accountant for 20
years right we're going to software for
ux designers i was a designer for 10
years they're either that or
they're
sales or marketing
that's what they should have now we've
seen where there's a developer and then
there's like
the business person the business guy or
what just means it's like anything
yeah it usually winds up meaning you're
not actually that helpful and you
probably shouldn't be a co-founder you
know if you can't sell or market or like
have input on the product
yeah or or develop it like those are
really the four roles um
you probably shouldn't be so if i'm if i
like i'm not tech i'm not technical but
i um
i can like i stuff together and use
zapier and i'm super creative how do i
start a star a software company without
hiring or i would if maybe hiring zit
but without having a co-founder right
so for you since you have money you
would either acquire something because
there's always stuff for sale that you
may want to acquire and then just grow
if you have a content marketing
expertise or you would hire you know a
developer or an agency or something to
build it
if you don't have the money
uh a lot of people
non-technical will work a day job and
actually funnel money to the side to
basically pay for a developer to do it
um
the other two approaches i've seen are
exactly what you said which is i'm gonna
build my minimum viable product using
zapier
and
notion and chewing gum all right and i'm
just going to cobble it together to the
point where hey if i get a few grand a
month in revenue this proves it and i'm
going to use that to get it built it's a
harder way to go but it's possible the
last one i've seen which is genius and
this is what the founder castos did
because he's not he's a single founder
not a developer he worked a day job he
started a productized service podcast
editing
and
he hi he got it up to i forget what the
number worth 30 or 40 grand a month in
productized podcast he was one of the
earlier ones it was called podcast motor
he was working a day job the whole time
so then while he was
actually doing the editing or he would
he did that first and then and then got
someone overseas exactly yep yeah yep or
even even has folks in u.s and canada
doing it um and there was enough profit
margin that he then started reinvesting
you know and said well now i want to
build now that i'm doing podcast hosting
he actually was in the podcast space
someone says i have this wordpress
podcast plugin for podcast hosting on
wordpress and i want someone to kind of
adopt it type thing since he was doing
something in public they approached him
he bought it for not very much money and
then he built the entire you know what
again is a seven-figure business he's
raised you know three aside from us he's
raised three quarters of a million
dollars and it's growing fast so that's
the other way to do it is like i even i
was a developer and i had to do it
nights and weekends too you know when i
was pulling money away from the day job
for the agency and
hiring a developer what what's the best
way to do that do a lot of these folks
like
a lot like when i was starting everyone
said like oh just go on odesk and hire
someone in india to do it and i'm like i
don't know man that doesn't sound like i
can like
like
yeah so like what are you
what what are there any agencies that
you like or for hiring devs are you
hiring someone by the hour in america
what do you typically see
yeah i typically see i see a lot of
people going either through referrals
like you get into a community um
microcom connect or indie hackers or
whatever dynamite circle and you ask and
you say who has used someone whom you
trust right so you try to get that
referral it's not just a a flat look
because going to upwork which used to be
odesk is kind of a show these days
the other thing is there are now these
uh
referral services aggregators there's
one called trust shoring which is run by
a guy who attends microconf but he
basically knows a bunch of eastern
european
dev agencies and if you come to him and
say i want to build an ios app he'll say
cool i have these three agencies that i
refer to he's almost like a broker in a
way but like he's a good dude and he
knows them you know and so he and he's
vetted them and then there's one called
clouddevs.com
and they do this similar thing for latin
america
and so
do you like cocktail or anything like
that top towels good it's expensive um
right because i think it's under 15
hours so it depends on budget and all
that if you're if you're scraping by i
haven't used top towel but i've had
friends use it and i heard quality was
really good in the early days and of
course like anything it gets you know
less and less but um that's certainly
something you could try too how much
would you budget to create an mvp
it depends on what it is you're talking
like a sas app here's the other thing
man
if you're if you are non-technical and
you've never started a startup before i
would say don't build a sas app it's too
hard like go i have this thing called
the stair-step approach to bootstrapping
which is like start small with like a
wordpress plugin a hubspot add-on a
salesforce add-on a heroku add-on and go
build that cut your teeth at it's way
less expensive way harder to maintain
and way easier to maintain you get the
experience you get some revenue then
grow it to enough that you can buy out
just buy out your day job eight grand
eight grand a month maybe 10 grand a
month then now you have experience you
can double down and
um and do it
that's awesome
to your question of building an mvp of a
sas app 10 to 30 grand power to throw it
out
but and you think a non-technical person
could actually maintain that and
understand what's going on
well no then you'd need to have that
agency sticker that's what i'm saying if
you're non-technical
um you either need some money and this
is why folks you build it
and your you pre-sell it
you get to the point where there's
enough revenue that you can then justify
you know raising funding right
if you're if you're not technical or you
have a side job that's uh
[Music]
you